hello my name is Russ Robbins for
Missouri City Texas when it congratulate
che game for your prize back in two
thousand six we want to know exactly
with this price has it opened more doors
for you and made the opportunity for
more research easier for you and how
have you handled your success at that
point in time thank you well hi Russ I
think you're bigger question is well how
has it changed my life to receive the
Nobel Prize and the short answer is I
get to go to an awful lot of parties and
have a and give a lot of speeches and so
in some ways that impedes my research
and holds me back but I also really
enjoy getting a chance to talk to people
to tell them about the beauties of the
universe and the mysteries of the cosmos
and how we're working on answering those
questions that we have so I enjoy being
a celebrated Nobel Prize winner and I'm
enjoying answering questions on YouTube
and has it changed my life a lot more
well try not to make it change much I
try to stay home I try to go to my work
and to keep on thinking about the big
questions of the universe